[musique]
Charles Rogeman, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous nous vous recevons pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Je m'appelle Charles
Remman. Je suis un obsédé de des
relations humaines, surtout qu'elle se
passe mal, comme c'est parfois le cas et
même souvent le cas.
Et je crois que ça vient de mon histoire
personnelle. Je suis né pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale. J'étais un
enfant caché. 1942. J'étais un enfant
caché. Mes frères ont été tués. Mes
grands-parents ont été tués pendant
cette guerre en Pologne. Alors que mes
parents étaient avec moi cachés.
Exterminés. Oui.
Mes parents étaient en France cachés.
Et donc je crois que depuis toujours,
j'ai été obsédé par ces questions autour
de la haine, du racisme, de des
mauvaises relations entre les gens, des
génocides, des guerres civiles. Et après
une beaucoup d'expériences
professionnelles très très diverses, je
me suis consacré à à faire un travail et
inventer une sorte d'approche qui permet
de mettre un peu plus de raison, un peu
plus de réalité dans les relations
humaines quand justement elle se passe
mal, quand justement il y a de la haine
de de des préjugés, de la peur, ce qui
est le cas partout, ce qui peut être le
cas dans des familles, dans des
quartiers, dans des dans des sociétés
entières comme au Rwanda où je travaille
aussi et aux États-Unis
dans les tensions entre blanc et noir
par exemple.
Alors, vous avez un parcours
universitaire, quel type de parcours
vous avez avant ?
Littéraire, je suis je suis parti de la
littérature.
J'aimais beaucoup lire. La lecture a été
ce qui m'a sauvé.
Je dirais la lecture et la sexualité et
plus tard la nature sont des choses qui
m'ont aidé à ne pas devenir fou. Malgré
cette enfance qui pouvait me prédisposer
à beaucoup de malaise psychologique. Et
donc j'ai tellement aimé lire que j'ai
commencé par faire des études
littéraires, ce qui était le plus facile
pour moi. Et puis petit à petit, j'ai
arrêté. J'ai pas voulu rentrer, j'ai
j'ai pas voulu rentrer dans le monde
universitaire. J'ai renoncé à
l'agrégation, l'école normale
supérieure. Je suis parti voyager, vivre
un peu au contact des gens un peu
partout dans le monde, des gens surtout
tout près de ces réalités très dures de
la vie sociale. Et donc j'ai vécu un peu
dans toutes sortes de pays, dans toutes
sortes d'endroits. Et puis petit à
petit, par le hasard des choses, j'ai
été amené à travailler dans une banlieu
qui s'appelle MT la Jolie, quartier du
Valfour avec un accord, un intérêt par
le du maire de la part du maire de M la
Jolie qui m'a laissé faire mes premières
expériences. Et donc à partir de là,
j'ai commencé à travailler beaucoup dans
pratiquement tous les quartiers.
Quand on est à gauche, on les appelle
les quartiers populaires. Quand on est
plus à droite, on les appelle des
quartiers difficiles. Mais en tout cas,
dans ces quartierslà, j'ai commencé à y
travailler.
Des zones à éducation prioritaire.
Oui. Des zones, certains disent des
zones de non droit. Enfin voilà, la
définition des mots dit bien aussi
l'idéologie qu'on qu'on met sur ces ces
quartiers-là. Et donc en travaillant
dans ces quartiers-là, au contact de la
violence, de la haine, des peurs, des de
des trafics de drogues et cetera, de la
jeunesse aussi en en dérive déjà à
l'époque dans les années 80,
j'ai commencé à inventer une approche
une
Il y a aussi des des des joies un peu
même au Valforé, il y a des joies, il
Oui, oui, bien sûr. Il y a des joies
mais la solidarité
bien sûr. Tout ça existe et on en parle
on en parle beaucoup et ça le fait d'en
parler beaucoup a fait qu'on a beaucoup
nié les réalités qui était déjà là dans
les années 80 et qu'on n pas tout
toujours voulu voir que moi j'ai vu,
j'étais aux premières loge donc je les
ai vu et j'ai j'ai inventé à ce
moment-là à partir de mes mes formations
de et de ma pratique de la
psychothérapie, j'ai inventé une des
méthodes de psychothérapie collective
sans avoir fait d'école de
psychothérapie ? Si si, j'ai fait une
école de psychothérapie, j'ai fait
beaucoup d'autres études, enfin j'ai
fait j'ai fait des j'ai fait des études
à à l'époque à Vincen de sociologie,
anthropologie, enfin je me suis
intéressé vraiment à tout et puis parce
que je suis pas un spécialiste, je suis
un généraliste et je m je suis un touche
à tout, je m'intéresse à tout et donc
j'ai une vision d'ensemble
pour avoir une vision d'ensemble et
surtout pour avoir une
c une façon inconsciente. Non non,
c'était clair pour moi. C'était une
manière de dépasser les disciplines, de
dépasser les cadres parce que j'étais un
enfant rebelle dès dès le départ. Et
donc j'ai voulu exploser les cadres.
J'ai pas voulu rentrer à Harvard où on
proposait une bourse. J'ai pas voulu
rentrer en à Normal Supera.
Et c'est ce qui m'a aidé d'ailleurs à
inventer ce que ce que j'ai inventé,
hein. Vous avez un institut
J'ai un institut
qui porte votre nom ? qui porte mon nom
euh qui est en France et en Suisse.
C'est payant pour venir chez vous pour
se former ?
Pardon ?
C'est payant pour venir se former chez
vous ?
Euh oui, c'est payant. Euh tarif
pardon
quel tarif ?
Euh je pense que ce sont les tarifs
habituels dans les écoles de formation
euh de l'ordre de 100 € par jour.
Et puis euh par contre, je travaille
souvent sur des commandes avec des
subventions qui sont données par des
gouvernements, des ministères, des ONG.
Quelquefois je travaille bénévolement
quand je suis passionné par quelque
chose que j'ai envie de voir et et
d'apprendre. Et donc j'ai inventé cette
approche transdisciplinaire
qui vise à comme je l'ai peut-être dit
déjà tout à l'heure,
vous avez un verre d'eau si vous voulez.
Oui. Oui. Merci. euh qui vise à mettre
de la de la raison et de la réalité
dans des relations humaine qui sont
obscurci par beaucoup de je dirais de
folie. Et ce que j'appelle la folie,
c'est vous az identifier trois trois
trois axes. Il y a il y a la
victimisation, la sociopathie et la ça
ce sont les maladies sociales. J'ai
identifié dans la société des maladies
sociales qui sont très banales, très
courantes. Il y en a une, c'est la
dépression, c'est-à-dire le manque de
confiance en soi, l'absence de projet
euh qui touche beaucoup de gens et puis
la consommation de la l'addiction, la
consommation et cetera pour pour
justement euh
conduites dangereuses aussi,
les conduites dangereuses, les conduites
de d'autodestruction
qui visent à oublier justement cette ce
sentiment de vie d'intérieur qui est
très fréquent aujourd'hui et en
particulier chez beaucoup de jeunes. La
deuxième, c'est la sociopathie,
c'est-à-dire le l'égoïsme. J'appelle ça
sociopathie. C'est c'est de l'égoïsme
social. C'est l'indifférence aux autres.
Tant pis pour les autres. Je suis ma
route, ma carrière et cetera.
C'est la dépression pour les riches.
C'est ça. Ça coûte un peu plus cher.
Non, c'est pas la dépression pour les
riches, c'est la corruption des riches
et la criminalité des pauvres.
C'està-dire, j'ai travaillé aussi en
Amérique du Sud, on a la même chose un
peu partout. En Amérique du Sud, on a la
criminalité des pauvres et la corruption
des riches. Et on a la même chose en
fait chez nous. La délinquence des
riches, c'est de la corruption, mais ça
suit un peu les mêmes les mêmes
tendances, je dirais psychologiques, à
savoir l'indifférence aux autres,
l'égoïsme euh et le narcissisme, toutes
ces choses-là. Et la troisième maladie
que j'ai repéré dans le dans la société,
c'est la victimisation. C'est-à-dire ce
qui m'arrive, c'est pas de ma faute. Je
suis pas responsable, c'est la faute des
autres. Alors les autres peuvent être
ceux d'en haut, ceux d'en bas, ceux d'à
côté, mais en tout cas c'est pas moi le
responsable. Et cette victimisation
aussi euh toutes ces ces maladies
sociales conduisent à beaucoup de
violence dans les rapports entre les
gens. Je vous une parenthèse qui qui n'a
rien à voir.
Si la la jeune génération qui va plus à
l'école pour dire "Voilà le climat est
pourri, vous êtes en train de je vais
parler vulgairement, vous m'excuserez.
Pas de problème."
Euh vous avez [__] la planète.
Oui.
On était pas responsable.
C'est de la victimisation. C'est quoi ?
Euh c'est de la victimisation. à partir
du moment où on ne regarde pas euh on
parle de façon idéologique sur le monde.
Euh on parle de façon idéologique et on
ne regarde pas concrètement euh ce qu'on
fait soi-même dans son environnement
immédiat avec ses frères, avec ses
sœurs, avec ses parents, avec ses
enfants, avec ses voisins.
Et et par exemple pour pour être plus
précis, moi je suis très méfiant
maintenant sur tous les mots qu'on
utilise y compris dans le monde
politique. Justice, liberté, fraternité.
Ce sont des mots. Ce sont des mots et
quelques mots
avec un t.
Des mots avec un t mot ts ce sont des
mots et souvent on fait le contraire de
ce qu'on ce qu'on dit. Et moi ce qui
m'intéresse maintenant de plus en plus,
c'est ce que les gens font très
précisément et de regarder à la loupe
euh exactement ce que les gens font ou
ne font pas qui contribuent, je dirais,
à leur propre malheur ou au malheur de
autour d'eux, au malaise de la vie en
société. Bon,
pour faire concret, c'est il faut
montrer l'exemple chaque seconde, c'est
ça ?
Non, c'est pas si si c'est pas chaque
seconde, c'est
incarner, c'est être capable c'est être
capable de voir de quoi on est
responsable.
Et dans le les le travail dont on aura
peut-être l'occasion de de parler de
travail avec des groupes ou avec des
individus, ce que le travail que je mène
de de thérapie collective, un des
objectifs, c'est que les gens cessent
d'être dans la victimisation.
pour une raison simple aussi parce que
la victimisation entraîne le sentiment
d'impuissance. Or aujourd'hui, le vrai
problème que nous avons dans nos
sociétés, c'est le sentiment
d'impuissance, c'est-à-dire
de l'impuissance. Oui, c'est c'est
l'idée que ce sont les autres qui
doivent bouger
euh et que soi-même et ben on est
impuissant à faire changer les choses
dans le dans le haut de la hiérarchie
sociale, j'appellerai ça du cynisme mais
c'est pareil, c'est un sentiment
d'impuissance. C'est à Bruxelles ça se
passe. C'est pas c'est pas nous. C'est
pas au à notre niveau qu'on peut faire
quelque chose. Et c'est pareil à tous
les niveaux de la société, on a cette
espèce de sentiment d'impuissance ou de
cynisme pour les gens qui sont gratifiés
par leur par leur vie sociale et par
l'argent en particulier. Mais on a
vraiment ce ça et c'est et c'est un
début de cette sortie de la
victimisation, c'est de donner aux gens
du pouvoir qu'on appelle en anglais
empment.
Excusez mon accent. Même on a le même.
Ah oui oui. Je travaille aux États-Unis
dans des pays anglo-saxons, mais j'ai
toujours un mauvais accent français. En
tout cas,
un mauvais accent français, un
magnifique accent français.
Un magnifique accent français. Je sais
que c'est très apprécié dans les pays
aux États-Unis en particulier. Bon,
alors donc je reviens à mon à mon sujet
à mon sujet. Vous essayez de me faire
dévier de sujet mais j'irai pas de ce
côté-là. Donc je reviens à mon sujet. Le
l'idée c'est de donner aux gens de la
puissance d'agir.
On en parle souvent de de cette question
de puissance de puissance d'agir, mais
on ne voit pas concrètement comment on
peut faire ça. Et si je pense par
exemple à un sujet qui a préoccupé
beaucoup de gens ces derniers mois, la
question des gilets jaunes qui me
passionne parce que j'ai vu enfin
quelque chose qui surgissait dans la
sauté française, une parole de gens
qu'on entendait jamais et donc j'étais
très heureux
d'entendre ces paroles-là et je me suis
rendu compte que c'était pas suffisant
parce que c'était une première parole et
moi dans mon travail ces paroles là je
les
qui sont des paroles revendicatrices,
victimisantes
et je pense qu'il faut créer un
processus pour que les gens arrivent à
dire réellement non pas le mal qu'ils
pensent de ce que font les autres mais
arrivent réellement à parler de leur vie
concrète, de leur vie réelle parce que
les gens savent beaucoup de choses. Vous
vous rendez compte ce que vous leur
demandez ?
C'est très simple.
C'est très simple. C'est il y a il y a
pas un proverbe qui dit euh pour pouvoir
ressentir à sa juste valeur, faut-il
encore pouvoir l'exprimer à sa juste
hauteur ?
Hm.
Bien sûr, mais je pense qu'on a besoin
d'une nouvelle éducation à la vie
démocratique aujourd'hui. C'est-à-dire
qu'on a besoin de d'arriver à retrouver
la la parole, mais une parole vraie, une
parole où les gens racontent réellement
ce qu'ils vivent.
Euh moi, j'ai fait par exemple des des
tas de rencontres entre euh des des tout
des ou des Israéliens, des Palestiniens,
des noirs, des blancs, des aux
États-Unis et cetera. Et à chaque fois,
je voyais que les gens commencent
toujours à parler de façon très
générale, très idéologique. Et le ce que
ce que je cherche à faire, c'est les
amener à parler de ce qu'ils savent eux
que personne d'autre ne sait parce que
c'est leur expérience de vie. Et pour
ça, il y a des conditions. Il faut avoir
confiance en soi. Il faut euh euh ne pas
avoir peur de d'être jugé par les autres
et cetera. Il y a tout sortes de
conditions que que j'aide à mettre en
place dans mon travail mais qui visent à
ce que les gens euh
par le vrai euh par le vrai
non seulement sur les autres, mais aussi
sur eux-mêmes et raconte vraiment ce
qu'ils vivent. Et je pense que la une
vraie vie démocratique, ça serait ça, ça
serait que que les gens parlent non pas
de ce qu'ils ne connaissent pas, mais
parlent de ce qu'ils connaissent
vraiment et que toute cette ces
paroles-là, que ce soi des paroles
d'électeurs du Front Nation, si je
prends l'exemple de la France des
expériences que j'ai faites d'électeurs
du Front National de G de G
pardon
ou de la République en marche
ou oui ou de la République en marche, je
sais pas mais plutôt de de les que les
gens parlent de ce qu'ils connaissent.
Et à ce moment-là euh ils disent des
choses très intelligentes parce qu'ils
parlent de ce qu'ils connaissent et
l'idéal c'est que ces parolesl soient
entendu et que
il pas plus il y a pas plus sourd que
celui qui ne veut pas entendre. Euh oui,
justement parce que le le monde
politique aujourd'hui est et surtout
pas dit le monde politique.
Oui. Oui. Moi je pense au monde
politique. Je pense que c'est un monde
qui est vraiment qui est fondé sur un
système de carrière et de gens qui euh
je sais plus qui disait le monde
politique aujourd'hui, c'est une agence
de placement pour carriériste.
Bon, je pense pour moi c'est un peu
vrai. Donc on a peut-être besoin
d'autres d'autres politiques au sens
homme et femme politique qui soi capable
de se remettre en question, d'être des
vrais leaders,
d'écouter,
d'écouter, d'écouter absolument et
d'écouter ce qui vient de la base euh
mais pas d'une base simplement pas les
pas les premiers mots, pas les premières
paroles. Euh moi je fais par exemple,
j'ai des groupes euh et
Attends attends attends. Oui. Oui. On va
faire preuve un peu d'empathie.
Oui.
D'accord.
On va se mettre à la place d'Emmanuel
Macron.
D'accord.
Et Macron, il peut rien faire. Il est
pied pied point lié. Il est coincé dans
une guerre économique mondiale qui est
sanglante. Vous savez pourquoi je disais
j'emploie sanglant ? Oui.
Parce que un chômeur coûte plus cher
qu'un mort.
Oui. Oui.
Donc c'est sanglant.
Oui.
On se retrouve avec une case sociale
dramatique, des marchés financiers qui
sont sous tension.
extrême.
Macron dès qu'il bouge,
je me fais je me fais son avocat, il se
fait taper sur les doigts tout de suite.
Alors, il graisse un peu la pâte de ses
copains directement pour faire passer un
Oui, mais on oublie dans tout ça, on
parle des grands ensembles, des grands
ensembles.
On on ne parle pas en terme suffisamment
psychologique, c'està-dire en terme de
un leader qui inspire confiance.
Macron n'est pas un leader qui inspire
confiance.
C'est pas quelqu'un qui de son de par
son caractère, de son attitude, de sa
manière de parler aux gens, c'est pas
quelqu'un qui inspire confiance.
Premièrement
il a le physique du genre parfait, il
est beau, il a une femme qui a de
l'expérience.
Ça ne suffit pas. Ça suffit pas pour
Non, ça suffit pas pour être un vrai
leader. Pour moi, un vrai leader, c'est
quelqu'un vraiment qui est capable
d'inspirer confiance.
Irénisme. C'est pas beau ça ?
Oui. Oui.
Qu'est-ce que c'est l'irénisme ?
Je sais même plus. Je sais même plus.
Mais c'est vrai que je suis pas très
intéressé par le monde politique tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui, les personnes
politiques telles qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui parce que j'estime qu'elles
sont euh
Si vous aviez un conseil à à donner à
Emmanuel Macron pour pour rentamer le
dialogue avec les gilets jaunes qui
rêvent que d'une chose, c'est entamer le
dialogue. Qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il
peut faire concrètement Macron ?
Est-ce que Macron il vous a consulté au
moins ?
Non.
Oh bah mince.
Non, il m'a pas consulté. Euh j'avais eu
avant avant le l'éruption du du
mouvement des gilets jaunes un projet
avec
une une femme qui est qui est apparaît
souvent dans les dans les grands comment
s'appelle les grosses dans les les
l'émission de radio Monte Carlot Zab
Habitan.
Bon, on avait un projet de
en étant aidé par tous les gens que j'ai
formé parce que j'ai des des écoles de
formation dans plusieurs pays mais en
particulier en France par en étant aidé
par les gens que j'ai formé d'organiser
des rencontres justement contradictoires
entre des gens qui ne se parlent jamais.
Euh et
c'est grand débat ça non ? Oui, mais le
grand débat c'est pas un débat justement
euh c'est pas un vrai débat. Ça a pas
été un vrai débat parce que on a on a on
a travaillé qu'avec des gens
volontaires.
Moi ce que je trouve très intéressant,
c'est quand on travaille sur des comme
je le fais comme je le fais moi, sur des
problèmes qui préoccupent les gens, qui
les font souffrir et quand on réunit des
gens qui ne pensent pas du tout la même
chose, qui sont même violemment opposés
et qui sont en en rapport de de violence
les uns avec les autres, qui ne se rend
compent jamais parce que si je reprends
prends l'exemple de ce que pourrait
faire Macron, Macron est face à une
société
qui est une société complètement
ghettoisée, complètement divisée avec
des gens qui ne se parlent plus, qui ne
se rencontrent plus,
avec des gens qui sont parfois quand on
a intérêt à le faire qui sont diabolisés
comme les électeurs du Front National.
Euh moi, j'ai eu dans dans tous les
groupes que j'ai organisé des gens qui
étaient des électeurs du Front National,
qui étaient des gens de gauche, qui
étaient des gens du sang, toutes sortes
de gens. Et j'ai vu à quel point lorsque
les gens sont mis dans un processus où
il ils commencent à avoir confiance en
eux, ils commence à à rencontrer les
autres, à les à à être dans un processus
qui amène à dire la vérité sur ce que
les sur comme je disais tout à l'heure
sur ce que les gens vivent. J'ai vu à
quel point ça pouvait créer de
l'intelligence collective et à quel
point cette intelligence collective
pouvait irriguer euh les gouvernants.
Donc si pour répondre à la question, si
j'étais pas,
ça fait combien de temps que tu fais ça
?
Ça fait une 30 Ça fait 30 ans.
[__] ça marche pas hein.
Euh si, ça marche. Ça marche mais ça
dépend des objectifs qu'on a.
C'est-à-dire
euh euh quand je travaille, je me fixe
des objectifs avec les gens évidemment
et je regarde ce qui est possible. Si
par exemple je réunis à Sanni, dans une
ville comme Sanni,
100 personnes qui veulent
parler de la violence parce que la
violence est endémique dans une ville
comme ça ni.
Les gens sont réunis dans une salle de
balle toute une après-midi et il y a des
gens qui sont communistes et qui pensent
que le problème de la violence c'est le
c'est le problème du chômage. C'est le
problème d'une société discriminante
raciste avec les jeunes en particul
d'origine africaine ou ou maghrébine
issu de l'immigration. De l'autre côté
des gens qui pensent qu'il faut plus de
police qu'il faut punir qu'il faut
exclure et cetera. foulard rouge.
Oui, tous ces gens l' réuni. Mon
objectif, c'est que il voi un intérêt à
se rencontrer et à se parler, c'est
tout.
C'est-à-dire que il découvre que ça peut
être intéressant de pas rester dans son
coin et d'écouter ce que pensent
d'autres personnes, c'est tout. Et alors
là, ça réussit puisque l'objectif est un
objectif très limité en fonction du
temps dont je dispose, des gens qui sont
là. Et donc à chaque fois, je réussis
toujours dans mon travail parce que je
me fixe des objectifs qui correspondent
à à au temps que j'ai. OK.
Euh voilà.
Bon, alors j'ouvre encore une parenthèse
parce que c'est l'après-midi, on a un
peu de temps, on est tranquille.
Oui.
Je te donne un cas concret.
Hm. Avec ma baguette magique, je te mets
ministre
avec un sourire malheur.
Oui.
Je te mets ministre de la paix sociale.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Euh, j'entame un processus de
réconciliation nationale.
Il fallait que tu commences par
j'augmente mon salaire.
Allez, continue. Bon, j'entame un
processus de réconciliation nationale en
partant de l'idée que comme dans toutes
les situations de préguerre civile,
parce que il y a on est déjà dans une
situation de guerre civile dans les
têtes, je pars de l'hypothèse qu'on a
déjà vu en Allemagne que des chercheurs
du Frankfort Institute a avaient déjà vu
dans les années 30 en Allemagne qu'on a
vu en Amérique centrale dans beaucoup
d'endroits, de l'hypothèse qu'il y a 20
% des gens qui sont vraiment très
radicalisés.
en France d'un côté comme de l'autre, du
côté identitaire par exemple en France
et du côté islamiste pour ce qui
concerne la population des des banlieux.
Oui. Oui. Mais bon, il y a 20 % de gens
qui sont très radicalisés et il y a 80 %
de gens qui sont ambivalents
qui peuvent basculer d'un côté radical
ou de l'autre. Euh et je pense par
exemple au côté identitaire, au côté
islamiste et cetera,
côté ultralibéral,
au le côté ultralibéral,
il a pas besoin de basculer, il est il
est il est déjà dans les dans les 20 %
de de gens radicalisés. La plupart des
gens sont ni libéraux ni antilibéraux.
Ils sont ambivalents, ils savent plus,
ils savent pas. Mais le problème c'est
que tous ces gens-là qui sont
ambivalents ne se rencontent jamais.
Il y a pas de rencontre. Il y a pas de
rencontre qui permettrait de sortir du
ghetto idéologique dans lequel sont les
gens. Les gens sont dans des ghetaos pas
seulement ethniques, pas seulement des
ghetos de riches ou de pauvres, mais
aussi dans des ghetaos idéologiques et
ils sont dans un milieu dans lequel il y
a une seule propagande
et il si j'étais ministre de la
réconciliation nationale
effectivement
euh c'est ce que je ferais, c'est-à-dire
je ferai en sorte partout d'organiser
des rencontres en sur des thèmes que que
des maires ou des élus m'aideraient à
choisir des thèmes où vraiment il y a
une une souffrance des gens, une envie
de changement et cetera et je mettrai
les gens ensemble et je créerai des
processus un peu partout avec des gens
que j'ai formés et qui sont capables de
le faire. Je créerai ces rencontres qui
sont des rencontres conflictuelles, des
rencontres dans lesquelles les gens
auraient la possibilité d'être en
conflit, de se cracher à la gueule tout
ce qu'ils ont à se dire, mais dans un
processus qui les amène à sortir de la
violence. Sachant que pour moi, la
violence, c'est de la déshumanisation de
l'autre. C'est-à-dire que l'autre, on le
voit plus comme
toi et moi, on le voit comme le
représentant d'une de quelque chose de
d'un peu monstrueux. Et ça c'est pour
les 80 % des gens. Et c'estes 80 % des
gens s'ils se rencontraient euh
deviendraient ensemble plus
intelligents. C'est l'expérience que
j'ai faite. J'ai fait cette expérience
par exemple en Allemagne à Dresd maire
de Dresdù où j'ai réuni des gens qui
étaient qui faisaient partie d'un
mouvement qui s'appelle Pegida, qui est
un mouvement contre l'islamisation,
contre l'islam, contre l'immigration.
Des gens qui faisaient partie de
mouvement euh plutôt d'accueil pour les
réfugiés. quand il y a eu cette affaire
de tous les réfugiés invité par madame
Merkel Mouti et et donc on a créé dans
plein de quartiers de Dresd, plusieurs
quartiers de Dress et puis aussi dans
des petites villes autour, on a créé ces
rencontres et ça a été formidable.
Il y avait des bookmakers ou pas ?
Des bookmakers pourquoi ?
Pour faire les paris pour celui qui va
survivre à la fin.
Non mais non, pas la peine. C'était pas
la peine. Euh à partir du moment où les
gens peuvent parler, peuvent crier,
peuvent être violents verbalement et
savent et ils savent qu'ils peuvent
l'être, bah ils ont plus besoin de la
violence physique.
Ça va, ça va tout seul. Et
ça se passe comment ? Les gens sont
enfermés dans la pièce, ils sont comment
? dans des grandes salles, ils sont par
exemple des groupes de 100 personnes,
ils sont dans des grandes salles et ils
sont ils sont dans une pièce et
effectivement il y a des il y a un
processus qui les amène à se rencontrer
par deux, par petit groupe et cetera
avec surtout de ma part et ça c'est très
important en tant que leader de ces
groupes, une attitude qui fait que les
gens sentent que je suis pas neutre, je
suis pas quelqu'un neutre, j'ai mes
propres
options, mes propres idées, mais je suis
au service d'un d'un ensemble. Les gens
savent, sentent, parce que je fais aussi
quelque chose pour ça, que je suis là
pour eux tous et que tous pourront
s'exprimer et que tous pourront être
entendus.
Et à ce moment-là, il se passe quelque
chose. Il se passe quelque chose. Les
gens
euh euh évidemment je je les mets pas
tous en bloc, en grand groupe, en disant
"Allez-y, dites ce que vous pensez parce
que là, il y aurait que de la la
violence, des invectives et cetera."
Non, je crée des situations où ils sont
amenés à parler d'eux-mêmes, à parler de
choses intimes et cetera, à se voir
petit à petit comme des des êtres
humains et petit à petit, il ils se
mettent à raconter. C'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure, à raconter
vraiment leur vie, leurs souffrances,
leur leur responsabilité aussi et
cetera. Et ça crée une circulation
d'information qu'on a d'habitude jamais
parce que les gens euh encore une fois
sont isolés. Et je
je peux te te remettre un un cas un cas
concret.
Oui.
Euh là c'est pour les gens à peu près
normaux. Bon, même s'ils sont Pegida ou
pas Pegida, bon qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec les 20 % de vrais sociopathes ?
Ceux ceux qui ont
On les laisse de côté.
Ah ouais, mais c'est compliqué s'ils
sont à la tête du pays ou ils sont s'ils
sont à la tête des des marchés
financiers ou s'ils sont à la tête de de
de Salm.
Ben comment on fait les révolutions
hein ?
On fait les révolutions. Comment on fait
les révolutions ? C'est le peuple qui
fait la révolution.
Quelle est la différence entre une
révolution et une révolte ?
Oui, une révolution c'est quand on en
arrière. une révolution. Moi, je suis un
un adepte de Jores, de Jean Joress et de
Mirabo.
La révolution, la première révolution
française, c'était Mirabo. Et
tu es un grand violent. Tu es un grand
violent.
J'ai été violent. Oui, je connais bien
la violence.
Alors, la révolution, on va la faire
comment ? En fait la vraie question,
la révolution elle se fait, je répète ce
que je disais tout à l'heure, peut-être
que tu l'as pas entendu,
la révolution, elle se fait parce que
les gens deviennent
réalistes dans le sens où au lieu d'être
dans l'idéologie, au lieu de parler de
liberté, de justice, de je sais pas
quoi, de marché financier, de et cetera,
il parle vraiment
d'eux-même et de ce qu'ils vivent. et
ils arrivent à ensemble à constituer une
force. C'est-à-dire le problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui face à des ensembles, je
dirais très très puissant euh
apparemment puissant, c'est qu'on a des
milieux populaires qui sont des milieux
euh comment dire séparés, des milieux
qui se voient réciproquement comme des
ennemis et on n pas cette cet élan
populaire qui est ce que moi je cherche
à créer. créé qui est euh euh qui existe
à partir du moment où les gens se
parlent réellement, où les gens se
rencontrent et où à ce moment-là
ensemble ils sont une force qui peut
agir sur les sur le monde qui les
entoure.
Tu es pas un peu tu es pas un peu un peu
utopiste ?
Si si, je suis très utopiste mais j'ai
des exemples précis des des choses comme
ça. Je prends un exemple. Je travaille
dans une ville de l'est de la France.
Euh, il y a un problème dans cette
ville, c'est une vie de quartier qui est
impossible. les enfants qui peuvent plus
aller dans les espaces publics,
l'insécurité, euh les espaces verts dans
lequel il y a des aiguilles de de de de
droguer et cetera et cetera
et donc de toxicoman et donc euh tout le
monde est préoccupé par ça. Mais il y a
deux groupes dans cette ville, deux
groupes qui se haïsent.
D'un côté des Arabes et des Turcs et de
l'autre côté des Alsaciens de souche,
presque tous électeurs du Front
National.
On réunit tous ces gens-là pour la
mairie. La mairie m'aide à réunir tous
les gens qui ont envoyé des lettres de
plainte, de revendication et de de
d'accusations de des autres groupes et y
compris des lettres racistes et cetera.
Tous ces gens-là ensemble se rencontrent
et
petit à petit avec ce processus qui est
que je pourrais décrire mais qui est pas
facile à à expliquer malgré tout, c'est
un processus thérapeutique, je dirais
presque de thérapie collective. Avec ce
processus, petit à petit, les gens se
parlent et se rendent compte qu'ils ont
des points communs. Que par exemple des
Alsaciens qui pensaient que les Arabes
ou les Turcs se foutent complètement de
l'éducation de leurs enfants se rend
compte qui que ces Arabes et ces Turcs
eux aussi sont préoccupés par
l'éducation des enfants, par les
problèmes d'insécurité et cetera. Et
donc il y a un après les premières
invectives où chacun accuse les autres,
vous vous êtes des racistes, vous les
électeur du Front National, vous êtes
tous des racistes, vous vous êtes tous
des délinquents, vous vous acceptez la
délinquence de vos enfants, vous faites
rien pour ça, les trafics et cetera.
Petit à petit, les gens se mettent à
dire "Bah alors, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ensemble ?"
Et à ce moment-là, ils se mettent à non
pas s'attaquer à la mairie, mais à
partir de toute cette information qu'ils
ont recueilli à faire des vraies
demandes, des vraies remarques à la
mairie, aux institutions, à l'école, au
logement social, à la police et cetera.
Euh et puis il y a évidemment des
rencontres qui sont organisées avec les
les acteurs du logement social, avec la
police, avec euh avec les élus et
cetera. Il y a un travail qui est fait
aussi avec les élus pour les aider à
mieux comprendre ce qui se passe, à
écouter et cetera. Et du coup, on a un
processus révolutionnaire que moi
j'appelle révolutionnaire que j'aimerais
euh comment dire généraliser parce que
j'ai vu euh j'ai vu qu'il marchait même
dans des situations comme au Rwanda où
je réunis des ex génocidaires avec des
survivants dont ils ont tué la famille.
Je vois bien qu'il y a il y a des
réconciliations possibles. Il y a des
réconciliations possibles et c'est cette
absence de réconciliation entre les gens
qui empêche la puissance je dirais
populaire et qui empêche que on puisse
agir
sur des institutions qui sont pas aussi
solides qu'on le croit et qui sont
constitu d'êtres humains qui peuvent qui
peuvent être capables de de aussi de se
remettre en question. Moi, j'étais très
frappé. J'avais écrit un article dans la
revue Causeur sur la nuit du 4 août en à
propos des gilets jaunes
1789 où les
fais-nous un petit un petit rappel pour
nos auditeurs.
Bah la nuit du 4 août, c'est une nuit où
les privilégiés de la noblesse et du
kerger ont abandonné volontairement leur
privilège.
On les a un peu aidé.
Euh non non non, c'était 89. C'était 89.
Il y a pas eu de euh il y a pas eu la
violence de la terreur. Euh c'était
vraiment le
la prise de conscience que euh ce qui
venait du peuple, c'était une aspiration
légitime.
Donc c'était des bourgeois de gauche.
Euh
non, c'est pas des bourgeois de gauche,
c'était vraiment des privilégiés qui
avaient des privilèges toutes sortes de
privilèges de la de chasse et cetera et
cetera qui qui bousillaient complètement
la vie des gens.
Et dans une nuit, ils ont abandonné leur
privilège réellement. Ils l'ont fait
réellement. Alors après, bon, ça s'est
pas trop bien passé. Il y a eu la
terreur, il y a eu Napoléon, tout ça,
mais
il y a un processus qui s'est enclenché
qui est le processus des temps modernes
avec la fin de la de l'absolutisme royal
et cetera. Il y a quelque chose qui
s'est passé et qui peut et qui peut se
reproduire aujourd'hui aussi. Donc c'est
c'est de l'utopie. Oui, mais c'est de
l'utopie fondée sur des expériences
concrètes et pas sur euh une idéologie.
Alors, deux choses. Quand Macron quand
Macron dit euh les mesures sociales, ça
coûte un pognon de dingue, ça sert à
rien, les gens ils sont toujours dans
leur pauvreté. Ça te fait quel effet ?
ben les faits que euh
et juste après, je te questionne sur ton
bouquin sur à propos de la guerre
civile.
Oui. Alors, l'effet que ça me fait c'est
que
il y a beaucoup de déniis et de
mensonges.
C'est-à-dire que moi personnellement, je
suis persuadé
que [grognement]
une grande partie
des des impôts, une grande partie des
des revenus
collectifs
sont gaspillés
euh parce qu'il y a pas de de vrais
travail de réflexion et aussi d'abandon
de certains privilèges.
Il y a pas ce travail là qui est fait et
d'après ce que j'ai pu voir et entendre,
je dirais queen ce qui concerne les
pouvoirs régalien de l'État, il y a à
peu près 20 20 % 30 % des impôts qui
sont réellement utilisés. Le reste,
c'est du gaspillage.
Pourquoi ?
parce que justement euh on a on a on a
une classe sociale de technocrates
qui ne connaissent pas réellement les
réalités de terrain, qui sont dans des
idéologies qu'ell soi libéral de gauche,
de droite et cetera et qui ne n'ont pas
justement cette connaissance de la vie
réelle des gens et et
ils doivent rembourser le la dette
française.
Oui, bien sûr, bien sûr. Mais ces dettes
françaises, il faut voir aussi comment
elles ont comment ell s'est constitué.
et cetera, comparer, voir que ce qui se
passe dans d'autres pays et cetera. Moi
je suis pas un économiste, pas du tout.
Non, mais tu sais que bon, c'est un peu
quand même louche ce qui se passe, non ?
Oui, je vois que c'est louche et je vois
qu'il y a beaucoup de sociopathie. Il y
a beaucoup Bon, c'est vrai que moi j'ai
un choc quand je vois que la que le
qu'on vend la Française des jeux euh et
que la femme de de
Leendre, je crois c'est ça, la femme de
Leendre devient la patronne de la
Française des Jeux et cetera. Gendre qui
est très pédagogue.
Oui. Qui est très Oui, j'ai j'ai déjà vu
son sa pédagogie, mais je vois je vois
qu'on a une classe dirigeante qui est
qui est soit pas à la hauteur, soit dans
le déni total des des vrais problèmes du
du pays, soit des voleurs et des
corrompus. Faut voir les gens.
Il y en a qui essayent de faire quand
même leur boulot.
Oui, mais mais ceux-là sont rapidement
éliminés à mon avis. À mon avis, le
système les élimine vite pour ne laisser
que des dirais des carriéristes et des
affairistes. Je suis un peu dur
peut-être. Je viens de lire les
les Qatar Qatar Papers.
Euh je viens de lire aussi le le récit
que fait un un chef d'entreprise qui a
été prisonnier au Qatar et qui raconte
comment les ministres de gauche de
droite les hommes politiques de gauche
de droite d'extrême gauche d'extrême
droite viennent au Qatar et repartent
avec des valises pleines de billets
ou des foulards.
Oui. Et moi j'ai vu ça et j'ai vu ça
dans les banlieux. J'ai vu comment dans
les banlieux on achetait la paix sociale
avec des valises de billets. Je l'ai vu.
Ça c'est avec mes yeux. ça
mais dans plein d'endroits, j'ai vu
comment on mettait en place un système
pour réussir à garder à rester au
pouvoir local à rester dans les à
réussir à gagner les élections. Comment
on achetait les gens ? J'ai vu ça à
Marseille, j'ai vu ça.
Oui, mais il y a pas que d'assaut.
D'assaut, c'est c'est l' pointe de
l'iceberg. C'est partout comme ça. C'est
partout qu'il y a il y a cette
sociopathie des classes dirigeantes.
Euh et comme il y a la sociopathie aussi
en bas, du coup il y a rien qui peut
bouger parce que euh tout le monde est
un peu dans cette histoire euh
sociopathe.
Est-ce que tu penses qu' qu'il faille
les médicaliser
médicaliser les
les mettre sous traitement ?
Non non, je pense pas. Tu tu es tu es
sûr que c'est on peut les on peut le
faire normalement par la parole ? Ils
sont pas vraiment atteints jusqu'à la
moelle ?
Je pense que beaucoup de gens sont
radicalisés comme je disais tout à
l'heure et puis qu'il y a une partie des
gens qui sont capables de se remettre en
question s'il y a vraiment quelque chose
qui se passe dans de de vrai dans le
pays. Ce qui est à mon avis ce qui a
failli ça pas failli arriver mais on
sent qu'il y a une aspiration avec ce
mouvement des gilets jaunes. On sent
qu'il y a eu un quelque chose comme ça
qui voulait commencer à exister.
et qui aurait pu aider à ce que certains
se remettent en question, que il y ait
des changements de personnel politique
et cetera parce que je on a quand même
il faut vous voir les choses, on a quand
même un personnel politique qui est mal
formé. Ça a été, je crois qu'il y a eu
un livre de Nicolas Tener et de la Croix
il y a quelques années.
Tenser
Tenser qui parlait la formation de l'ENA
et qui expliquait pourquoi cette les
formations de l'ENA pouvaient pas aider
réellement à pratiquer l'écoute et à
travailler en coopération avec
le la la avec la la le avec le pays. Et
moi je pense que on a ça aussi. On a
quand même des formations de de
responsables politiques, de conseillers
et cetera qui sont des formations très
technocratiques et qui justement sont
très idéologiques et ne tiennent pas
compte euh de la des réalités vécues.
Bon, parlons un peu de la guerre civile.
Oui.
Tu as écrit un bouquin là-dessus ?
J'écris un bouquin vers les guerres
civiles parce que j'avais le sentiment
que dans toute l'Europe aujourd'hui et
aux États-Unis aussi, dans le monde
occidental,
on a une guerre civile dans les têtes.
Euh beaucoup ça tourne beaucoup autour
de la question de l'immigration,
l'identité,
l'islam et cetera.
On a des des séparations idéologiques
très grandes
qui peuvent aboutir à
une guerre civile réelle.
Sachant que les guerres civiles que j'ai
beaucoup étudié dans plusieurs pays,
c'est un processus qui demande certaines
conditions. Donc les conditions ne sont
pas réunies pour le moment, mais le
potentiel de haine dans la société
française,
c'est quoi les les conditions ?
Alors, les conditions, c'est que euh il
y ait des événements dramatiques,
traumatisants,
euh
un tsunami, euh une épidémie. Non non,
je pense plutôt à des des attentats de
très grande envergure. Euh des combi
envergur,
je sais pas des des quelque chose qui
crée vraiment de la peur des peurs
collectives.
Et puis euh il faut qu'il y ait des
un potentiel de haine qui est monté
depuis plusieurs années, ce qui est le
cas en France. il y a un potentiel de
haine qui monte depuis à peu près 40 ans
et qu'il y ait des un prête à penser
idéologique qui est en train de de se
mettre en place d'ailleurs euh un prête
à penser idéologique, c'est-à-dire des
idéologies d'exclusion des uns ou des
autres et puis finalement après il faut
une autorité légitime qui donne l'ordre
de
commencer la guerre.
Et c'est ce que j'ai vu au Rwanda, c'est
ce que j'ai vu au Yougoslavie, c'est ce
que j'ai vu Cambodgeoslavie, tu as vu
quoi ? Bah, ça c'est-à-dire que à partir
du moment où il y a eu une autorité
considérée comme légitime, euh ça a été
par exemple pas seulement Milozevic mais
ça a été aussi les du côté croate et du
de des autres côtés aussi, il y a eu des
autorités qui ont dit euh euh vous
pouvez tuer
et là il y a des guerres civiles.
Donc il y a c'est un tout un processus
que j'ai étudié. Je l'ai étudié en
Allemagne aussi parce que en Allemagne
on croit souvent que Hitler est arrivé
comme ça par hasard en en 1933 avec sa
bande brute de SA de SS et cetera. En
fait tout ça était à aé pendant des
années des années dans les universités.
Il y avait une idéologie, on parle de
prête à penser idéologique. Il y avait
une idéologie qui s'appelait l'idéologie
Fulkich qui avait pénétré petit à petit
toute la jeunesse allemande, toutes dans
les universités et un potentiel de haine
antisémite en l'occurrence qui est monté
progressivement depuis 1918 et la le la
guerre la peur des bolcheviques et la et
la guerre la fin de la guerre perdue par
l'Allemagne avec l'humiliation du traité
de Versailles et cetera parce que tout
ça aussi en rapport
Et petit à petit donc cette ce potentiel
de haine a est monté monté un prête à
penser idéologique qui a été la pensée
fulkich transformé ensuite en pensée
national socialiste et un gouvernement
qui arrive au pouvoir et qui dit vous
pouvez tuer.
Et là on n pas eu une guerre civile, on
a eu une une persécution et le génocide
des des juifs.
Et on oublie souvent,
et ça c'est une chose sur lequelle je
beaucoup insister, je parlais tout à
l'heure des technocrates, des
gouvernements et cetera.
Presque toujours ces violences
collectives sont générées au départ par
des intellectuels
presque toujours. Les politiques
viennent après, mais au départ, ce sont
des intellectuels. Au Rwanda, j'ai
rencontré les planificateurs du
génocide. Tous des intellectuels, des
psychologues, des sociologues, des
prêtres. C'était les planificateurs du
génocide en Allemagne. Les les Einzat
Groupen qui ont été d'ailleurs
probablement qui ont tué mes ma famille,
c'était ces ces groupes qui suivaient
l'armée allemande et qui tuaient d'abord
au départ les bolcheviques et puis euh
et puis ensuite les juifs femmes et
enfants. C'était était conduit par des
docteurs en philosophie, en philologie,
par des haut personnages de l'université
allemande.
Des bons sociopathes.
Des bons sociopathes au Cambodge, c'est
pareil. Les gens Paul Potte et compagnie
et tout et tous les gens autour de Paul
Pot, c'est des gens qui avaient fait
leurs études à la Sorbonne. Donc ce
qu'on voit pas toujours dans ces
histoires là, c'est que ça commence
toujours par le haut. Euh,
tu en as identifié là chez nous là des
intellectuels un peu comme ça ?
Ben, il y a ce qui se passe en ce moment
aujourd'hui dans les universités, ce
mouvement décolonial,
tout ce mouvement soi-disant antiraciste
euh qui
est est en complicité très grande avec
les islamistes et qui Oh oui oui oui,
bien sûr. Les islamistes
frères musulmans particuliers ont
parfaitement compris comment
fonctionnait notre société et ils
utilise
siamment, consciemment et siamment
toutes les valeurs de notre société,
c'est-à-dire le féminisme, le
l'individualisme,
le l'antiracisme
pour faire avancer leur cause. et ils
ont des aides idéologiques
qui
contribuent aussi à à développer ce ce
que j'appelle ce prêt à penser idolque.
Mais le prêtre à pensée idre côté et on
risque d'avoir justement ce phénomène de
guerre civile entre d'un côté
en fait deux idéologies
l'une
qui se prétendrait antiraciste et
l'autre qui se qui se dirait plus
identitaire. Et donc là, il y a
effectivement un risque euh qui pour le
moment n'existe que dans la tête des
gens. Mais je dis toujours que ce qu'a
fait Brévic
euh 50 % des Français de souche, si on
peut employer ce terme-là, pense que
pense la même chose que Brévic.
Ça vient d'où ce chiffre ?
C'est mon c'est c'est absolument pas un
chiffre scientifique.
C'est ce que je sens en me baladant
partout partout dans tous les milieux.
la cité française depuis des années. Je
sais que beaucoup de gens par exemple
qui ne sont pas des électeurs du Front
National, qui sont pas des identitaires
déclarés pensent la même chose mais sont
restent silencieux, reste dans
l'abstention, reste dormant mais c'est
ce qu'il pensent. Et je pense que d'un
autre côté ce qu'a fait Mera et des gens
comme ça dans le dans le
dans la population qui est de culture
musulmane, je pense que aussi 50 % des
jeunes en particulier pensent que
ben ont des théories complotistes sur le
gouvernement français dominé par les
sionistes sur et cetera. Il y a vraiment
ce que j'appelle ce potentiel de haine
qui existe aujourd'hui dans la société
française et qui est dormant. On s'en
l'aperçoit pas. Je je j'aime bien
toujours donner un exemple. Je donne un
exemple. Je connais une anecdote. Je
connais une petite ville de Bourgogne
euh du nord ou du sud ?
De Joan. Il s'appelle Joannie. Petite
ville tranquille.
dans la dans cette petite ville, il y a
un marché et dans ce marché, il y a un
vendeur de bandes dessinées. Sont les
bandes dessinées sadique qui représente
des gens à qui on ouvre le ventre euh
pour sortir les boyaux, euh les femmes à
qui on coupe les seins, de gens qu'on
décapite et cetera.
En Bourgogne, ça
en Bourgogne à joigner. Je demande au
vendeurs, "Mais ça marche ? Dessiner dit
mais c'est fou, il y a plein de gens qui
viennent me les acheter et qui les qui
les achètent, qui me les redonnent, j'en
j'en vends d'autres et cetera." Ça veut
dire que dans une petite ville comme
Joanille, il y a des gens, beaucoup de
gens, je peux pas évidemment, j'ai pas
de statistique, qui se repaissent de ce
genre d'horreur.
Ouais. Ou sinon, tu t'es fait un peu
embrigader par un forin qui t'a raconté
un peu n'importe quoi.
Non, je sais, je sais que c'est vrai. Je
connais, je je connais ça et j'ai connu,
j'ai vu ça au Rwanda pareil. Comment au
Rwanda des gens tout à fait normaux
pouvaient assassiner leurs voisins, même
leurs femmes ou leurs enfants et cetera.
Je je peux pas raconter tout ce que je
je sais du Rwanda, mais tout le monde
sait que les horreurs qu'il y a eu au
Rwanda et qu'il y a dans d'ailleurs dans
beaucoup de guerres civil en Algérie, il
y a eu aussi des des horreurs euh
comparables euh en Syrie aujourd'hui
dans beaucoup d'endroits de de la Israël
aussi.
en Israël. Euh non, juste
il y a pas de des choses satiriques sur
les Palestiniens et inversement.
Non, euh il y a beaucoup de
euh je dirais que c'est c'est un peu
différent. C'est un peu différent parce
que je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de de
comme il y a une une rapport de
domination, il y a beaucoup plus de
haine du côté palestinien que du côté
euh
il y a quand même du côté israélien, il
y a quand même
Oui. Oui. Il y a du Il y a du racisme,
ça existec. Là, j'ai lu un papier,
c'était un papier du monde de 2018 ou
2016.
Euh un Israélien qui comparait le le
gouvernement en place qui avait des
pratiques proches de de du début du
nazisme. Vous avez lu le même ? Non. Bah
je sais mais je pense qu'il y a la même
chose en France. On a en France
une une partie de la population je dis
éclairée éduquée qui est beaucoup dans
la repentance et la la
l'autoflagélation.
et qui est euh qui est très marqué par
je dirais du une sorte de christianisme
ou de marxisme qui fait que le dominer a
toujours raison et le dominant a
toujours tort. Mais ça ça nous
entraînerait très loin de parler de ça
mais c'est vrai que ce sont des sujets
qui m'intéressent beaucoup.
Déjà vous avez déjà été amené à faire
discuter des Israéliens avec des
Palestiniens ? Bien sûr. Oui, oui, oui.
Genre du cou avec en face
euh Oui, c'était des gens des gens Bon,
j'ai eu deux expérience. Une expérience
une fois avec des responsables
israéliens euh journalistes,
ambassadeurs,
responsables gouvernementaux et les
responsables palestiniens du côté à
l'époque c'était Arafat, des ministres
d'Arafat, le ministre d'affaires
religieuses d'Arafat. Et donc, il y a eu
une rencontre comme ça avec euh aussi
des étrangers, des ambassadeurs de des
États-Unis. Enfin, j'avais organisé,
j'avais participé à l'organisation d'une
rencontre comme ça euh qui était
d'ailleurs très étrange parce que je
m'étais aperçu que entre responsable
israélien et palestinien, il y avait
beaucoup de liens d'amitié
et beaucoup de relations surtout qui ne
font jamais état dans le dans la vie
publique. Donc ça m'a ça c'était quelque
chose que j'avais vu de très
intéressant. Et puis j'ai organisé des
rencontres mais entre citoyens
israéliens et palestiniens euh en Israël
et en S Jordanie. J'organise ces
rencontres qui étaient très très
intéressantes, qui démarrait évidemment
avec beaucoup de violence, avec beaucoup
de diabolisation réciproque. Vous vous
êtes tous des terroristes, vous êtes
tous des assassins et cetera et cetera.
Puis petit à petit, comme je disais tout
à l'heure, les gens parlaient vraiment
de leur vie. Les Palestiniens parlaient
de la violence qui existe dans la
société palestine aussi, c'est-à-dire de
ce qui se passe réellement dans la
société palestinienne, des violences
conjugales, familiales,
sociétales et cetera. Les Israéliens
fais pareil, c'est que quand on enferme
tout le monde dans une seule pièce, ça
commence à
et petit à petit et petit à petit, il y
avait une humanisation qui se faisait de
l'autre où les Palestiniens disaient
jusqu'à vous êtes toujours mes
adversaires parce que on est des
adversaires parce que on veut la même
terre et cetera mais à partir d' présent
je vois plus comme des monstres mais
comme des êtres humains.
Et malheureusement
eu un des épisodes qui m'a vraiment
choqué, c'est que ces Palestiniens qui
étaient extrêmement hostile, agressif
avec les Israéliens,
vice
Versa,
moins moins. Il y avait moins de
d'hostilité du côté israélien
que du côté palestinien.
Euh mais il y en avait aussi bien sûr.
Et simplement ce qui s'est passé c'est
que dans la nuit à un des épisodes que
auquel j'ai assisté les des gens sont
venus c'était en en 6 Jordanie et ont
menacé de mort les Palestiniens qui
participaient à ces dialogues en les
accusant de normaliser la situation
parce qu'il parlait a des Israéliens.
Donc la plupart d'entre eux a dû partir
et du côté israélien, il y a à peu près
la même chose. Non
non, il y avait pas ça du côté isra
quand par exemple il y a un un couple
mixte qui se forme et que la partie euh
dure sioniste euh
Oui. Oui.
bloque le le
Non, non, mais il y a des il y a des
choses qui existent euh comme en France,
comme en Europe, on a des mouvements
identitaires en Israël comme on a des
mouvements identitaires en
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour enfin les réconcilier ?
Bah, c'est toujours la même chose. Je je
je pense qu'il faut travailler sur des
sujets concrets qui intéressent les
gens. En si je prends l'exemple du
Rwanda. Au Rwanda, je travaille pas à
réconcilier les ex-assins et les et les
survivants. C'est pas le but. Le but,
c'est de parler de choses concrètes.
C'est-à-dire ils vont revivre dans le
même village. Comment ils vont faire
pour continuer à travailler ensemble ?
Comment on fait pour créer une
coopérative ? Comment les les
ex génocidaires vont restituer les biens
pillés ? Parce qu'il y a eu des pillages
de bien pendant que les hommes tuaient,
les femmes pillaient les maisons.
Donc il y a des ils doivent discuter de
la restitution des biens pillés, soit en
nature, soit en argent et cetera. Donc
ça c'est ça qui fait venir les gens.
Mais en travaillant sur des sujets
concrets, petit à petit, les gens se
réhumanisent
et
se mettre à accepter de vivre ensemble.
Il faut courtcircuiter les politiques
pour reconnecter les peuples ensemble.
Je pense. Oui, je pense. Tel que tel qu'
est aujourd'hui la politique, oui, parce
que il y a beaucoup de mensonges dans la
politique. Les
responsables, une des raisons qui font
que la le la si Jordanie est très
prospère, plus prospère que la plupart
des pays arabes. Euh, on voit plus de
voitures de luxe à Ramala que à Tel
Avive.
Oui oui oui mais j'y étais quand même.
Je j'ai vu comment ça se passait. Tu
la vive, il y a eu des grands mouvements
sociaux.
Oui oui bah je finis l'idée. Euh la
raison c'est que les rond de
palestiniens font des affaires avec les
Israéliens
et que les les je dirais les les
politiques
font leurs propres affaires sur le dos
des peuples et ça les arrange de que les
peuples soi restent divisés.
Ça c'est c'est la sociopathie des des
dirigeants et elle est elle est réelle.
Revenons à notre sujet. Euh les guerres
civiles.
Oui, les guerres civiles.
Là là tu as identifié en Europe un ter
potentiellement fertile
dans toute l'Europe. En Allemagne, je
l'ai vu aussi. Il y a la même chose.
Et euh ça va ? Tu le perçois bien ? Tu
arrives à dormir ?
Et j'aimerais qu'on parle d'épigénétique
juste après.
Oui, j'arrive à dormir parce que je n'ai
plus pas d'illusion.
J'ai pas d'illusion. J'ai je suis
euh euh ce que j'appellerais un
pessimiste actif, c'est-à-dire je suis
très pessimiste mais actif. Et puis euh
j'aime beaucoup une phrase de Gramchi
que je cite toujours qui est
extraordinaire. Gramchi disait il faut
avoir le pessimisme de l'intelligence et
l'optimisme de la volonté.
Je trouve ça super.
C'estàd qu'il faut voir les choses comme
elles sont effectivement puis voir aussi
les causes, les origines et cetera. Moi
je m'intéresse beaucoup à l'histoire et
je vois comment les les phénomènes sont
aussi générationnels.
Je veux dire ce que on vit aujourd'hui,
ça a été aussi créé par la guerre de
141. Ce que le Moyen-Orient vit, c'est
aussi créé par les accords Sispicau des
années 2018, l'effondrement de l'Empire
ottoman et cetera. Donc, il faut
s'intéresser à toutes ces choses-là. En
tout cas, moi je m'y intéresse beaucoup
à l'histoire et donc j'ai pas
d'illusion, je dirais d'une part, j'ai
pas d'illusion sur l'être humain.
Bah oui, l'être humain est capable du
pire comme du meilleur. J'ai vu le pire
aussi. Je l'ai vu dans beaucoup
d'endroits. Quand on parle de guerre
civile, j'ai vu ce qu'était une guerre
civile. J'ai vu des horreurs et entendu
des horreurs inimaginables. Inimagina
[raclement de gorge] ou Liberia à la
belle époque.
Non mais j'imagine
les gens à qui on coupait des bras, les
chemises, comment on appelle ça ? Les
chemises courtes et cetera. J'ai
manche longue, manche courte.
Manche longue, manche courtes. J'ai
aucune illusion sur l'être humain qui
est capable de du meilleur du pire. Mais
je suis très enthousiasmé par le la
capacité qu'à l'être humain justement de
d'être dans la dans la coopération, dans
l'amour si les conditions sont
favorables. C'est un peu je reviens à ma
mon approche. Euh en fait c'est un peu
comme dans une famille. Quand dans une
famille un enfant est suffisamment
sécurisé, valorisé, aimé, il a moins de
chance de tomber dans la peur, la haine
et la folie. Dans une société, c'est la
même chose. Quand dans une société, il y
a peu de sécurité, peu de valorisation
des individus,
peu de lien entre les individus,
le pire le pire arrive. Donc dans ma mon
approche, je crée les les cadres, un
cadre qui fait que les gens vont être
sécurisés, valoriser, être en lien les
uns avec les autres et ça fait ressortir
quelque chose qui est qui est la
capacité de l'être humain à à être à
être à être bien avec les autres, à
comprendre les autres, à être
empathique, à écouter les autres et
cetera. Et je vois à quel point nous
sommes en tant qu'être humain très
plastique et dépendant de notre
environnement
familial, sociétal, politique,
économique, culturel et et alors c'est
là qu'il faut agir. En fait, il faut pas
agir en voulant changer l'être humain
parce que l'être humain peut pas
changer. Il faut créer les conditions.
Alors, ça peut être à mon humble niveau
dans les groupes de thérapie sociale,
mais ça peut être aussi au niveau
collectif,
c'est créer les conditions où il y aura
moins de peur qui conduisent à la
violence et à la haine. Et aujourd'hui,
on vit dans une société qui développe
beaucoup les peurs. Euh, peur de la
chute sociale, peur de plus avoir de
sens, peur de des autres qui sont à côté
de nous. euh parce qu'on vit avec des
gens qu'on a pas forcément avec lesquels
on n pas choisi de vivre.
Euh et donc toute
le vivre ensemble, tu as tu as une
vision sur le le vivre ensemble ? Ben
moi, je suis j'ai inventé le terme il y
a quelques années qui a été repris qui
s'appelle vi vivre ensemblisme. Je suis
contre le vivre ensemblisme,
c'est-à-dire vivre ensemble,
c'est-à-dire aimons-nous, euh faisons
des efforts pour euh pour nous
comprendre, pour nous aimer. C'est de la
blague pour moi. C'est de la blague
parce que chez les êtres humains, il y a
de la cruauté, la méchanceté,
la folie, la du profil, la convoitise,
la cupidité, tout ce qu'on veut. Et puis
il y a aussi de la violence contre
soi-même, de l'automutilation,
la destructivité, la toxicomanie et
cetera. Il y a tout ça. Ça, c'est les
êtres humains. Donc vivre ensemble, ça
veut rien dire. Vivre ensemble
en même temps, c'est une nécessité parce
qu'on a pas le choix. On est bien obligé
de vivre ensemble mais il y a des
conditions qui sont nécessaires pour
qu'on arrive à vivre ensemble.
Lesquels ? un environnement qui euh ne
crée pas de peur, qui crée moins de
peur.
Or aujourd'hui, le l'environnement
économique, social, politique crée
beaucoup de peur
et ces peurs conduisent à la à la haine
et à la violence. Bien sûr. Je veux dire
quand quand on a peur de pas avoir de
sens, ben on cherche un sens fanatique.
Par exemple, quand on a peur de la chute
sociale ou de la pauvreté, et ben c'est
la délinquence et la corruption
ou la dépression
ou le suicide
ou le suicide. Il y a tout ça et c'est
lié avec les peurs et la seule chose
qu'on a à faire et que les responsables
politiques devraient s'attacher à faire
s'ils étaient vraiment au service ou
mais s'ils peuvent pas parce que s'ils
sont malades,
s'ils ont une sociopathie alors je suis
pas tout bib mais si s'ils sont on va
dire s'ils ont le syndrome du mégalop le
mégalomanus il y a deux possibilités
soit il y a quelque chose qui se crée au
niveau populaire
et qui pousse leur coupe la tête
peut-être pas
alors à l'ancienne c'est peut-être pas
la seule solution mais qui pousse à à ce
qui est des changements. Oui bien sûr.
À lesquels ? une grèffe de la fin
généralisée,
une
des gilets jaunes pendant 4 mois,
une vraie révolution qui soit pas ce que
je disais tout à l'heure qui soit pas
uniquement dans la victimisation et la
revendication mais qui soit dans
l'affirmation
de justement, je reviens sur ce que je
dis tout à l'heure, de ce que les gens
savent et de l'intelligence qu'ils ont
lorsqu'ils sont délivrés de euh des
peurs, des préjugés de euh et qu'ils se
réunissent et qu'ils se rencontrent avec
d'autres gens qui qui pensent pas comme
eux. Voilà, ça c'est un peu
on voit que les franc-maçons, ils ont
totalement échoué.
Oui. Et et le les usars noirs de la
République aussi ont échoué ont échoué
parce que il y avait il y avait quelque
chose comme ça effectivement dans ce
qu'on appelait l'éducation civique,
il y avait quelque chose qui qui faisait
tenir le pays et qui était respecté
aussi par des par des hommes politiques
parce que les hommes politiques le le
arrier. Moi, j'ai beaucoup justement je
il y a pas beaucoup d'hommes politiques
que je respecte dans le passé maisquel ?
Bah je dirais Mand France de Gaul,
Jores, Léon Bloom, c'était quand même
des gens qui avaient un peu des statures
de d'homme d'état.
Macron, c'est pas ton copain ?
[rires]
C'est pas Macron lui-même. C'est c'est
tout un milieu, je dirais. C'était
pareil avec un peu avec avant dans les
les gouvernements précédents, je dirais
c'est tout un milieu euh je dirais
dominé par la technocratie.
Tu votes ?
Euh
non.
Pourquoi tu
depuis quelques années, depuis de ou 3
ans, je vote plus parce que je vois plus
pour qui je vais voter. Par contre, je
me suis un peu engagé dans un nouveau
parti
qui est
qui s'appelle la République souveraine
et qui a été créé par un dissident de de
la France insoumise
qui s'appelle comment ?
Georg Kuzmanovic.
Ah,
et tu crois ? [rires]
Les mots ? Oui, j'aiécouté les mots. Je
trouve ça intéressant le j'aime bien le
côté républicain, laïque,
souverainiste sans sans rejeter
l'Europe. Mais j'aime bien ce côté-là,
le côté chevainemente.
Chevin deement, c'est quelqu'un tiens
oui, chevinement, quelqu'un qui m'a
beaucoup aidé aussi dans le passé, en
particulier dans mon travail que j'avais
commencé avec la police nationale. Et
donc j'ai j'étais intéressé surtout si
on me confie le la charge des des
questions de laïcité de de
réconciliation nationale
parce que je me suis rendu compte que
pour que j'arrive à généraliser mes
approches, mes méthodes et cetera,
je peux pas le faire en étant en
position de demandeur auprès de
politique, mais je peux peut-être le
faire plus en étant moi-même même
prescripteur et en disant voilà voilà ce
qu'il faut faire. Donc ça m'intéresse
aujourd'hui avec mon grand âge, je me
dis et ben c'est peut-être le moment euh
le moment d'être prescripteur et de et
de dire ce qu'il faudrait faire.
Bon l'épigénétique ça te fait penser à
quoi ?
Précise un peu plus.
Euh, imagine-toi le stress
d'une famille
qui influence sa ses terreurs nocturnes,
sa sa capacité à se développer
normalement qui se reproduit, qui se
transmet de génération en génération, ce
stress
Oui.
du biotope sur le l'évolution psychique
des futures générations.
Euh bah, ça c'est très présent, hein. Ça
c'est très présent partout. C'est pour
ça que je me garde de vouloir mettre
simplement en cause le le je dirais le
monde d'en haut, le monde politique
parce que je vois que les violences
existent aussi à tous les niveaux de la
société. Violence de quartier, violence
de famille.
Je vois par exemple que dans une cité de
banlieu comme j'en ai connu une dizaine
de jeunes de 15 à 30 ans peuvent
bousiller la vie des habitants bien plus
que les multinationales
bien plus. C'est-à-dire que concrètement
s'il y avait pas d'évasion fiscale, on
pourrait mettre un peu plus de
fonctionnaires qui qui qui s'occupent de
l'éducation. C'est pas on a fait on a
fait tout ça, on a fait tout ça. C'est
pas une question de moyen.
Non non non mais je veux dire bien sûr
l'évasion fiscale mais l'évasion fiscale
pour moi c'est tout à fait comparable à
la criminalité qu'on trouve et à la
sociopathie qu'on trouve à tous les
niveaux dans la société. Il y a des
sociopathes partout
et des sociopates qui font du mal.
Il y a de des pères de famille ou des
mères de famille qui bousillent leurs
enfants. Et donc moi personnellement, ce
qui m'intéresse, c'est pas de d'isoler
le mal uniquement à un endroit de la
société, mais de voir qu'on a quelque
chose de systémique où la violence, elle
est elle est à tous les niveaux et où il
faut travailler justement à tous les
niveaux.
Mais ça c'est une question de de aussi
de volonté politique, de mettre en place
des formations de de gens capables de
gérer les problèmes quotidiens des gens
et cetera, ce qui est pas le cas
aujourd'hui.
On va prendre deux trois questions
internet qu'on vient de me faire
remonter. Euh je vais les piocher euh au
hasard.
Alors, quand on voit certaines violences
policières, il y a des victimes. Comment
être parfois victime sans être dans la
victimisation ?
Ben, justement, euh, il y a tout un
travail à faire sur différencier victime
et quand on est vraiment victime et
quand on est dans la victimisation.
Il y a des victimes réellement.
Euh il y a des victimes, si je prends
l'exemple de la police, il y a des
victimes
des violences policières. Il y a des
victimes des violences contre la police
aussi. Beaucoup de de violence contre
les policiers, beaucoup de
Kakatof créer des des stress
psychologiques chez l'agent de police,
c'est une calamité. Bah, j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec la
empêche de dormir hein.
J'ai Chevinement m'avait demandé de de
travailler sur la police de proximité.
Une vraie police de proximité, pas une
police simplement qui joue au football
avec des jeunes, mais une vraie police
de proximité qui soit au contact des
habitants des quartiers. Donc, j'ai
travaillé là-dedans. J'ai fait la
formation des formateurs de la police
nationale et là, j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses. J'ai appris beaucoup de choses
sur la violence dans l'institution
policière elle-même.
Catastrophique.
La violence sur les policiers qui vient
de la hiérarchie
euh et avec des comment
[raclement de gorge] dire en cascade. En
cascade. Et puis et puis effectivement
la violence contre des citoyens mais
aussi la violence de de citoyens contre
les policiers.
Et donc pour moi c'est c'est on est
toujours dans une dans un système et on
peut pas être dans un quelque chose de
maniquéin en disant
les mauvais ce sont les policiers ou les
mauvais ce sont les habitants des
quartiers. C'est vraiment quelque chose
de de systémique avec des peurs
réciproques et des haines des haines
réciproques.
Si je te dis l'État est le seul
détenteur de la violence légitime,
euh oui, l'État est le seul détenteur de
la violence légitime.
Oui, bien sûr, mais à condition que
cette que les personnes qui sont à
détenteur de cette violence
soit
soit pas des gros sociopathes.
Soit pas des gros sociopathes. Voilà,
c'est ça. Or, des sociopathes, il y en a
à tous les niveaux de la hiérarchie
policière et il y a des sociopathes dans
les quartiers de la même façon.
Donc donc c'est
si tu veux moi je m'inscris contre toute
proposition maniquenne c'està-dire toute
proposition qui ne voit le mal qu'un
seul endroit de la société
parce que là fatalement on on ne réussit
pas à créer quelque chose de nouveau. On
est uniquement dans des affrontements
qui conduisent à à l'impuissance ou à la
guerre.
Autre question la guerre, on va y
revenir. Autre question d'internet.
[gémissement]
Vous avez dit par les vrais ?
Oui.
Mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire parler
vrai à l'heure des fake news et de la
persécution des lanceurs d'alerte ?
Parler vrai, c'est parler de ce qu'on
connaît. C'est parler de la réalité. Or,
la plupart du temps, notre vision de la
réalité est filtrée par nos émotions,
nos passions, nos idéologies, nos
médias.
Nos médias, mais les médias qui vont
dans le sens aussi de de nos propres
fantasmes aussi.
On appelle ça filter bubble. Oui, c'est
ça. C'est vraiment ça. C'est-à-dire que
les médias euh à la fois contribuent à
créer les fantasmes, renforcer,
à les renforcer et en même temps euh euh
sont aussi victimes des propres
fantasmes des gens eux-mêmes. Euh donc,
je pense que parler vrai, c'est pas la
vérité. Moi je je crois pas la chacun a
sa vérité. On dit comme on dit toujours
Pirandelo avait déjà dit ça à chacun sa
vérité mais je crois que la réalité
existe et le but du du travail qu'on
doit faire c'est d'arriver à mieux
comprendre sa propre réalité de ce qu'on
est vraiment soi-même en bien et en mal
la réalité du monde qui nous entoure.
C'est c'est vraiment ça cette réalité.
On nous a appris avec le relativisme de
la déconstructionnisme que la réalité
existe pas, que chacun a sa vision de la
réalité. Oui, chacun a sa vision de la
réalité. La réalité, elle existe. Et une
manière de trouver la réalité, c'est de
mettre ensemble encore une fois des gens
qui pensent pas la même chose et qui ont
des informations très différentes sur la
réalité.
Est-ce que Est-ce que le gouvernement
chinois t'a déjà contacté ?
[raclement de gorge]
Non, pas
il t'ont pas appelé, ils t'ont pas
appelé pour discuter de leur programme
de rééducation des igours.
Non, ils t'ont pas appelé pour ça.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de la de la
méthode chinoise de réconciliation des
peuples, de de dialogue entre les les
les petites minorités ? Cette capacité à
à être
Franchement, je ne la connais pas. Je
non franchement je sais pas du tout ce
que font les Chinois
avec les cours.
Oui oui, je sais simplement il
les parc il leur manger du porc.
Oui oui je sais ce que ce qu'on me
raconte. C'est c'est un peu si tu veux
l'avantage de mon travail c'est que ça
m'amène à travailler dans des milieux
très différents.
Et quand j'arrive dans ces milieux-là,
que ce soit au Guatemala ou en Rwanda ou
en Allemagne ou partout, j'arrive
toujours en disant aux gens, "Je n'ai
que des préjugés sur vous
parce que
ce que je sais dans les endroits où je
travaille, mais ça peut être pareil en
France, ce ne sont que des préjugés."
C'est-à-dire euh dans mon travail,
j'essaie pas de diriger les gens vers
l'approbation de ce que moi je pense.
D'accord. Qu'est-ce que tu penses du
système chinois ? La notation, la
notation par intelligence artificielle,
par caméra de reconnaissance faciale,
les passeports.
A priori, j'ai un préjugé défavorable. A
priori a priori. Oui.
Le fait le fait de faire manger du porc
à des musulmans,
je ne je ne sais pas si c'est vrai, je
ne sais pas comment c'est fait. Je ne je
ne me prononce pas parce que je connais
pas cette réalité. Si par contre j'avais
la possibilité d'être en Chine et de
travailler avec des wigours qui me
racontent vraiment non pas des trucs
idéologiques sur la Chine ou sur les
Chinois mais qui me racontent leur vie
quotidienne. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Comment qu'est-ce qu'on leur fait ?
Le port laqué
siel goût.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Ce que je
veux dire c'est moi je travaille que à
créer les conditions pour que les gens
parlent de la réalité.
Et à partir de là, je me forge mes
idées. Mais mes idées pour moi sont des
préjugés, sauf quand je parle de ce que
je connais.
Euh par exemple, je peux dire que
j'étais très étonné de voir la
prospérité des villes
de Palestine de Sjordanie.
Et quand je compare,
il y en a il y en a qui mangent du sable
un peu quand même, non ?
Oui, mais je suis très étonné quand je
compare par exemple à ce que j'ai vu en
Égypte. ou en Tunisie ou en Algérie. Et
là, je sais parce que j'ai vu. Donc je
me fais une idée de ce que je sais. Je
sais par exemple que je prends un autre
exemple que dans la police nationale il
y a des rapports hiérarchiques
exécrables. Là je peux dire parce que
j'ai vu, j'ai entendu [grognement] mais
sur ce que je ne n'ai pas vu, je n'ai
que des préjugés et ça peut être des
préjugés favorables. Donc j'ai un
préjugé favorable sur le système
chinois. Mais je peux pas en dire plus.
Ouais, j'ai j'ai beaucoup à dire. Euh
alors, autre question d'internet.
Comment faites-vous avec les personnes
réticentes
qui veulent la sission dans la société ?
Comme j'ai dit,
il y a très peu de gens, une minorité de
gens qui sont radicalisés, une majorité
de gens veulent cette sion aussi,
ont un rejet, par exemple de l'autre,
rejet par exemple euh Non, ça va, merci.
rejet des Arabes qui est qui est la
principale motivation des électeurs du
Front National. Euh oui oui, mais ça je
le je le sais depuis je suis le truc
depuis très longtemps et je pense c'est
ça la vraie motivation. Avant c'était
les Arabes, aujourd'hui c'est les
musulmans. Je pense c'est la vraie
motivation des électeurs du Front
National, la principale motivation, je
dirais avant même l'Europe, avant même
d'autres d'autres sujets plus
économiques. C'est vraiment ça le la
base. Euh donc j'ai l'habitude quand les
gens arrivent, ils sont ils sont
là-dedans, ils sont dans la dans la
haine, dans la peur, dans la violence et
cetera et ils peuvent l'exprimer. Je
crée les conditions pour qu'ils peuvent
l'exprimer et c'est petit à petit parce
que les gens sont respectés dans ce
qu'ils pensent que petit à petit ils
élaborent plus
de la complexité surtout s'ils sont en
contact avec des gens qui pensent pas
comme eux.
Autre question d'internet ? Attends
avant que je pose la question
d'internet. Ça va, ça te fatigue pas
trop de rencontrer que des gens qui ont
des problèmes qui qui veulent uniquement
se sur la gueule contraire au contraire
parce que quand je vois comment les gens
sont capables de se transformer à toute
allure en en gen respectueux,
[toux]
généreux
et cetera, je suis toujours très
enthousiasmé par mon travail. C'est un
travail très enthousiasmant et très euh
comment dire gratifiant ré nourrissant
nourrissant. Tu as pas envie d'en
attraper un à gauche, un à droite et de
les scouer très fort et de leur dire non
ça suffit vos conneries.
C'est pas des conneries. C'est pas des
conneries. C'est leur réalité. C'est ce
qu'ils ont besoin de dire et c'est pas
des pour moi c'est pas des conneries
simplement
qui est du diable.
He oui oui oui oui oui, j'ai bien
compris. Mais non, au contraire et à
partir à partir du moment où les gens
peuvent aller plus loin, où on les juge
pas tout de suite, toi tu es mauvais, tu
es un raciste, toi tu es tu es un salot,
tu es et cetera. Les gens se disent à on
m'écoute, je peux dire ce que je pense.
Donc il commence à aller plus loin et
plus ils vont loin, plus ils rentrent
dans la complexité.
Donc question internet. Comment on
s'assure que les tensions s'expriment
dans un groupe sans que le groupe
explose ?
Le groupe n'explose jamais parce qu'il y
a un processus qui font que les gens
petit à petit se font confiance
et qu'ils sont capables d'entrer en
conflit
à partir du moment où ils ont confiance
où ils ont confiance les uns dans les
autres et donc ils explosent pas parce
qu'ils ont jamais la possibilité d'être
en conflit. Ça qu'il faut qu'on
comprenne, c'est qu'on est dans des
sociétés où il y a pas d'espace du
conflit, il y a pas de d'éducation au
conflit. Les gens peuvent pas être en
conflit. Comme ils sont pas en conflit,
ils se rencontrent pas et il ils
élabordent des idées les uns sur les
autres et ça devient de la violence
quand ils ont l'occasion de se
rencontrer.
Ça c'est un peu comme les chiens qui
sont chacun de leur côté de la barrière
et quand on ouvre la barrière, ils
arrêtent de s'aboyer dessus.
Peut-être. Oui.
Alors, autre question d'internet. Euh
comment prenez-vous en compte la
violence du système économique qui
s'exerce sur les individus dans vos
ateliers ?
Ça fait partie de tout l'environnement
euh euh qui crée de la qui crée de la
peur. Euh cette violence du système
économique, elle est euh elle est pas
que il y a pas que la violence du
système économique. Il y a il y a tout
le système culturel, idéologique qui
crée de la peur chez les gens. Et je
pense qu'une des erreurs, ça serait
d'isoler uniquement les problèmes
économiques comme la cause de ce qui
fait souffrir les gens. Je pense que les
gens souffrent de tas d'autres
problèmes, de problèmes de voisinage, de
problèmes d'identité, de problèmes
sexuels, de problèmes affectifs et
cetera. Et la focalisation sur
l'économie justement permet de d'éviter
de parler d'autres choses. Or, c'est il
faut parler de tout.
Euh, autre question d'internet.
Avez-vous plus de mal à faire se parler
les classes populaires qui s'opposent
comme en Alsace ou à faire parler les
classes différentes des riches et des
pauvres pour schématiser ?
Je pense qu'il est plus facile de faire
parler ensemble des classes populaires
qui s'opposent.
Riche et pauvre, ça dépend ce qu'on
appelle
riche et pauvre.
Rich et pauvre, je te prends un cas
concret.
Oui.
Un trader qui gagne 100 millions d'euros
à l'année.
Oui.
Un petit trader, d'accord, qui a
l'habitude de passer ses vacances sur
des des beaux bateaux et qui aime faire
des gâteaux à la farine.
D'accord.
Oui. Oui.
Je te l'emmène à Saint-Denis.
Oui.
Bon, il va avoir un choc.
Bon, admettons, on fait l'inverse. Je
prends quelqu'un de Saintque, j'emmène
sur un yach. Oui,
il va avoir un choc.
Oui.
Est-ce que tu penses pas que il y a une
catatonie émotionnelle quand on voit la
le fossé qui sépare tout ça ?
Oui, absolument. Euh, absolument. Moi,
je je pense qu'on peut travailler
qu'avec des gens qui ont intérêt à
changer quelque chose. Les gens qui
profitent, par exemple, d'un système
sont des gens qui ont pas du tout
intérêt à entrer dans ce type de
processus. Et moi, je travaille pas avec
eux. dans une cité par exemple, je
travaille pas avec les les
comment dire les les gros délinquants
euh qui dirigent le trafic de drogue de
la cité par exemple parce que ils ont
pas intérêt à on
considère comme une menace.
Euh
non parce que j'arrive à leur faire
comprendre que je vais pas toucher à
leur
à leur fric. Oui oui. Alors à leur
histoire de fric mais que je travaille
dans l'intérêt de des de leur petit
frère et de leurs petites sœurs dans
l'intérêt de leur famille et ils sont
sensibles à ça.
Tu penses que le alors je je prends ces
[soupir][souffle coupé]
je je caricature mais tu penses que le
trader il a aussi envie de de ça ?
Je pense que le trader en soi n'existe
pas. Le trader est une personne et parmi
ces personnes, il y a probablement de
tout. Il y a des vrais
des malades mentaux.
Très bien.
Il y a des gens peut-être qui seraient
capable de remettre en question. Moi,
j'ai connu des gens qui qui
abandonnaient tout, qui abandonnaient
leur leur fortune et cetera pour mener
une vie plus conforme à leur idéal et
cetera. Donc je pars pas d'avance avec
des préjugés
sur les uns sur les autres.
Euh autre question internet. Comment
fait-on pour s'emparer de vos outils si
on veut faire des rencontres pour faire
baisser la tension ? Tu vas nous dire
100 € par jour une formation chez toi ?
Non, moi j'aimerais euh j'aimerais qu'il
y ait des moyens qui soient euh donnés
pour que pour que cette forme
d'éducation à la vie collective soit
généralisée.
Tu sais vraiment pas de vente Charlin.
Là, tu dois dire "J'ai écrit des
bouquins, tac tac tac tac tac, quelle
édition ? Quelle année ! Allez !
D'accord. D'accord.
Alors, quel bouquin tu peux conseiller ?
Euh si c'est un bouquin qui concerne les
beaucoup les questions de de cité et
cetera, c'est violence dans la
République, l'urgence d'une
réconciliation
à la découverte. Euh le livre sur les
guerres civiles, malheureusement je
pense qu'il est épuisé.
Euh et puis il y a les prochains que je
vais écrire.
Tu en as déjà écrit beaucoup des
bouquins, non ? Oui, mais pas
suffisamment parce que j'ai je suis
tellement pris par la pratique, par la
le développement de de la méthode du de
ce travail là que j'ai pas assez de
temps pour écrire et donc j'ai envie de
va falloir parce que 76 ans c'est plutôt
jeune.
Oui, je sais, je sais, je sais. Je suis
au courant.
La transmission des savoirs machin,
c'est bien d'être dans l'actif tout le
temps mais bon, il faut je m'en occupe.
Ça fait partie de mes décisions de vie.
Autre questionnet. Euh euh vous parlez
d'autonomie des gens. Est-ce que vous
voyez alors attends attends est-ce que
vous alors est-ce que vous voyez comme
anarchiste ?
Euh non, pas vraiment. pas vraiment
anarchiste parce que je pense que
l'autorité
à tous les niveaux dans une société que
soit au niveau familial, au niveau
scolaire, au niveau sociétal doit
exister, mais qu'on a besoin aujourd'hui
d'une d'un nouveau type d'autorité qui
est plus l'autorité
qui sait tout, qui se remet jamais en
question, l'autorité, je dirais le
modèle patriarcal. Aujourd'hui, on
arrive, on est dans une autre une autre
société. Donc à la fois les responsables
politiques, les responsables
institutionnels, les parents, les
maîtres et cetera doivent aujourd'hui
rester une autorité qui est garante et
protectrice, mais ils doivent
entamer un processus de changement qui
aujourd'hui est nécessaire parce que le
le monde a évolué et que on n'est plus
dans un monde où le où les enfants ne
savent rien, où les les subordonnés ne
savent rien. Les les femmes sont des
sont soumises à l'autorité du mari.
Aujourd'hui, on est dans un autre monde.
Et justement dans les sociétés qui
n'arrivent pas à quitter le modèle
patriarcal, ça va poser ça pose de gros
gros problèmes aujourd'hui avec une une
des tentatives de régression vers ce
modèle patriarcal qu'on voit en parc
dans aujourd'hui dans le monde
arabo-musulman. Il y a une régression
vers ce par peur de
dans le monde arabé
du monde plus il y a la même chose en
Amérique du Sud,
la même chose en Israël hein.
Oui, c'est un monde je dirais euh dans
tout le monde qui est vraiment dominé
par le patriarcat, il y a ce même genre
de difficulté avec le dans la relation
avec le monde moderne.
Tu es pour plutôt la polygamie ou la
polyandrie ?
les deux.
Ah,
il nous a tué là. [rires]
C'était une question.
C'est une question sur internet ou une
question personnelle ?
Autre question.
Oh, j'ai fait beaucoup d'expérience dans
ma vie.
Ah, on veut pas le savoir. Oui.
Alors, comment n'ont pas sombrer dans le
niilisme et où sortir ses proches de
celui-ci ?
Tu
question ?
Oui.
Comment ne pas sombrer dans le niilisme
? et et où sortir ses proches de
celui-ci quand ils sont dans le niilisme
?
Je je pense que
une bonne paire de claque.
Non non, je pense que le niilisme est
provoqué par la le manque d'espoir
euh et que
et que quand il s'agit des proches, il
faut créer un cadre pour que les proches
se sentent
valorisés, sécurisés, aimés.
Et c'est le manque de cette réassurance
qui crée le vide intérieur et le le le
niilisme justement.
Pas mal.
Pensez-vous que Xemour fait partie des
intellectuels qui préparent au pire ?
Question d'internet.
H
non, personnellement, je pense que
Zemour est un
lucide pessimiste
et qu'il voit euh des évolutions de la
société mais qu'il a pas d'outil de
transformation.
Il a pas de
Il n'est qu'un polémiste
mais un polémiste qui dit une partie de
la réalité.
C'est quoi qui dit comme réalité ?
ben qui dit que
que l'Occident a perdu foi en en ses
propres valeur
qui a une menace totalitaire à l'horizon
qui est pas seulement incarnée par
l'islamisme mais aussi par l'islamisme
et que
le danger fasciste est toujours présent
et qu'il est pas toujours là où on
pense.
Autre question internet. Vous avez plus
peur d'une guerre civile euh que d'une
guerre entre états.
Tu es à sec [grognement]
un petit peu.
J'ai pas de peur.
Tu as pas peur ? Non, j'ai pas peur.
J'ai pas peur.
J'ai peur ni d'une guerre civile, ni
d'une guerre tout court. Je pense que
c'est à à nous de faire en sorte c'est
notre notre œuvre, notre devoir de faire
en sorte que
nous puissions arriver à vivre à vivre
en paix.
Alors, ça c'est une question perso. Tu
connais Christin Murti ? Oui oui,
j'étais
j'ai travaillé avec Richard Mourti dans
les années 60 sur la pédagogie puisque
j'habitais près de là où il habitait
aussi et que j'avais des amis donc qui
qui me l'avait fait rencontrer l'avait
fait connaître. Donc je l'ai connu
personnellement dans les années 60. Oui.
Pas mal.
Autre question internet. Qu'est-ce qui
semble une violence une violence
légitime si cela existe ? Est-ce qu'il y
a il y a des violences qui sont
légitimes ? Ben euh le problème c'est
que souvent on confondence et conflits.
Euh la violence c'est vraiment la
déshumanisation, c'est la représentation
de l'autre comme étant
pas un être humain comme moi. Euh par
contre ce qu'on appelle violence
quelquefois c'est du conflit et le
conflit peut s'exprimer avec euh colère,
agressivité
et ça peut paraître violent. Mais pour
moi, je fais une distinction entre les
deux. Euh pour moi la violence c'est
vraiment elle est dans la représentation
qu'on a de de l'autre.
Pour toi c'est violent de de démanteler
les hôpitaux, de démanteler les services
publics, de C'est une violence pour toi
?
Il y a plusieurs sortes de violence. Il
y a euh il y a de la maltraitance,
il y a de la l'humiliation,
l'indifférence,
la sociopathie, c'est une forme de
violence évidemment.
et penser qu'à son profit au profit de
son groupe pour moi c'est c'est de la
violence.
Euh on arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
interview. Je vais juste piocher
peut-être encore une dernière question
sur la liste d'Internet.
[souffle coupé][soupir]
Ah oui, très bien ça. Est-ce que le
service militaire était encore un
endroit de mélange de classe de
territoire ?
J'ai connu le service militaire. Euh
j'ai connu moi-même le service
militaire. Euh c'est vrai que dans la
dans une chambée de 50, on était on
avait il y avait des intellectuels, des
étudiants, des paysans, des ouvriers.
Oui, il y avait un mélange un mélange de
classe et une sorte de effectivement
quelque chose qui qui n'existe pas,
c'est-à-dire cette possibilité de
rencontre et de discussion entre des
gens qui faisaient pas partie du même
milieu.
Si je te dis collège interarmé de
défense qui change en école de guerre,
est-ce que tu as un avis sur le
ministère de la défense ? Est-ce que
c'est nécessaire d'avoir une armée pour
si vispassem par Abelhomme ou si
vispassem parassem ? Qui veut qui veut
la paix prépare la guerre ou qui veut la
paix prépare la paix ? Est-ce qu'on a
encore un intérêt ? Est-ce qu'on n'est
pas encore une espèce archaïque à se
taper dessus avec des bâtons
technologiques ?
Bah si l'être humain
si l'être humain est uniquement
rationnel
et capable justement d'entendre raison,
on aurait pas besoin effectivement d'une
d'une armée mais c'est pas le cas. Et
donc je pense que si on avait pas
d'armée, on serait à la mercie de gens
qui en ont une.
Et donc
j'ai sur le ministère de la défense,
j'ai pas d'avis arrêté mais je pense
qu'une armée
l'armée [raclement de gorge] fait partie
de de la défense de la nation.
Je suis joressien. que Jor a écrit un
livre s'appelle l'armée nouvelle et où
il défendait cette idée-là et la
révolution française n'a pu n'a pu
survivre
que parce qu'elle avait elle avait
l'armée sinon elle aurait été étouffée
dans l'œuf dès le départ par les armées
de d'Autriche et de et de des empires
anglais et et autrichiens.
Donc on arrive à la fin de notre
interview. Charles ? Oui.
Euh euh on a pour habitude de de
demander un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, de laisser une bouteille à
la mer,
quelque chose d'impérissable.
Euh
à toi.
Et bien, je crois que les jeunes
générations
doivent devenir
révolutionnaire
mais pas révolutionnaire
d'une façon maniquienne, mais
révolutionnaire en regardant
partout où il est où il y a un besoin de
de changer quelque chose qui est violent
et injuste
sans préjuger et en essayant le plus
possible de coller à la réalité.
Charles Rogeman. Merci.
Merci.
[musique]